I was first involved with Village  organizations and helping to organize  events in the village when not enough  people stood for the parish council it  was suggested I might like to stand and  and I did four years later when an  independent Council on team Ridge was  retiring she suggested that I stood for  teambridge so I've been there now the  last 36 years  um as an independent it is more  difficult initially to to get yourself  elected because of course you need to  become known but once you've done that  it becomes easier and of course you're  not affected by the national political  situation so things do get easier as  time goes on